where am i you've been under ever since
you slept doing the gritty at your super
bowl party been about six months six
months
oh
that's just pre-season do you want me to
go tell your family you're awake nah but
you can let me know if the seahawks
finally got russell wilson some help oh
boy
let's fry oh my god what else happened
devonta adams is on the raiders now
rogers isn't going to like this ayah
what scott do you have any hinds i'll
use ketchup named after my favorite
football field so let me get this
straight aj brown is with the eagles
antonio brown is on soundcloud and amari
cooper is on the browns i mean that's
good for baker
well then who's the browns qb what the
[ __ ] one shot one shot oh
nice kyler by the way don't you have a
game tomorrow congrats on the giants job
do you know who bibi is well at least my
qb isn't carson wentz matty ice where's
wince what's a commander can you believe
i got tariq in the fourth round not
surprising since he won't be catching
passes from the homes anymore huh
hey your wife and kids are downstairs
want me to send them up no not yet yeah
it's gonna be real exciting seeing joe
and troy on espn this season julio jones
sign with the bucks
who's gonna throw him the ball
he's back
no
i'm about to miss kickoff